(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] The first
thing about Mexico City
that will grab you is the
city's immense sprawl.
The second thing is the food.
(upbeat music)
The street food of Mexico
City reflects the ingredients
of the entire country and history
that spans hundreds of years.
(upbeat music)
In the neighborhood of Juárez,
you can find an ingredient
that at first glance,
may seem off-putting; but,
it turns out, corn fungus
is a Mexican flavor to be reckoned with.
(upbeat music)
(majestic music)
(calm, soothing music)
(Nicolasa speaks in foreign language)
Head toward the Anthropology Museum
and down a pedestrian
walk, and you'll find Ana,
selling Dorilocos, a dish
that certainly lives up to its name.
(chill music)
(Ana speaks in foreign language)
A 10 minute cab ride
later can find you eating
some of the best octopus you've ever had.
You can't miss this vendor
because his cart takes
up half the sidewalk.
(upbeat music)
(Diego speaks in foreign language)
In the neighborhood of Hipódromo,
there is one street corner you can't miss
because the tortas here
are said to be some
of the best in the city.
(upbeat music)
(Perla speaks in foreign language)
Down in the Historic
Center, there is a block
jam-packed with vendors, but B-line it
to Fany's stand for her
take on the tlacoyo.
It's a traditional Mexican street snack.
(upbeat music)
(Fany speaks in a foreign language)
(Fany laughs)
(chill guitar music)
And finally, back in Juárez,
a man named Francisco Solis has a stand
with a few stools and a
dish that you can smell
from blocks away.
(chill guitar music)
(Francisco speaks in foreign language)
(upbeat music)